hi I'm Eric Boston Aquaman was a lot of
fun for the more cynical view where it
may not fix everything that you've taken
issue with in the DC movies but you know
it's a good reminder that from Finding
Nemo to The Little Mermaid to spongebob
under the sea it's a party just be glad
film only requires two senses because
while it looks real pretty
we're like the ocean stinks I'm gonna
break down Aquaman scene-by-scene for
all the interesting details director
James Wan snuck into the movie that you
might have overlooked Easter eggs to
Juan's past work under the DC Comics
none of the literary and mythology
influences in this film and spoiler
warning in case you haven't seen the
movie ed and me telling you more about
everyone's your life okay this one opens
with Thomas curry battening down the
hatches of his lighthouse in a misty Bay
this of course is where Aquaman seaman
father Thomas curry lives in the new 52
comics he's played here by tomorrow
Morrison who played Jango Fett in Star
Wars Attack of the Clones he sees down
below stranded on the rocks is Queen
atlanna Nicole Kidman the imagery here
could be a reference to Greek mythology
which is a big part of the inspiration
of the Aquaman character the figure
Andromeda was chained to the rocks by
the sea to be fed to a monster from the
sea god Poseidon as punishment for
mother Cassiopeia is hubris so not only
does Atlantis visuals here allude to
Andromeda she also suffers a similar
fate with the Atlantean sacrificing her
by throwing her to the monsters of the
trench during this we hear the voiceover
from their future son Arthur curry
Aquaman played by Jason Momoa he recites
this quote put two ships in the open sea
without wind or tide and they will come
together he says this was written by
Jules Verne he's the author of several
classics including 20,000 Leagues Under
the Sea and I think what's most
interesting if you look up the bull
quote Verne goes on to say place two
enemies in the midst of a crowd and they
will inevitably meet so this quote kind
of applies to both the inevitability of
Tom and Atlantis meet-cute but also the
meet not so cute between Aquaman and
Black Manta who declares we were bound
to meet at some point inside the
lighthouse the TV plays an old TV show
of a submarine this is actually the 60
series stingray which also features
underwater races of creatures and a
kingdom ruled by a tyrant
just like in this movie Atlanta is
literally a fish out of water here and
her behavior here seems largely
influenced by Daryl Hannah's mermaid
character and the Tom Hanks rom-com
movie splash but Atlanta in this Tom
also fall in love and if you look around
the home they raise baby Arthur in
you can see a few interesting Easter
eggs first the snow globe sits upon this
book filled closely at the title this is
the Dunwich horror by HP Lovecraft James
one mentioned Lovecraft as a huge
influence on his horror imagery as a
film director Lovecraft is known for
gargantuan looming tentacled monsters
lurking in the shadows of a cosmos or
the depths of the ocean on a personal
level he's also known for being a pretty
bad human being so even when it comes to
authors don't meet your heroes look
crafts most well-known monster is
Cthulhu a monster who has inspired all
kinds of things that we've seen and
shows like stranger things and as we'll
see later the massive creature of this
movie the Caruth n' 100% Lovecraftian in
its design also on the side table look
at this object it looks like some kind
of shell based decor but it looks a lot
like a mother box remember mother box
were the three MacGuffin objects that
Steppenwolf used in Batman V Superman
and Justice League to open a wormhole
and a ride to earth the decoration could
be a recreation of the mother box in
Atlantis which they still possessed at
this point the timeline before
Steppenwolf would have arrived to steal
it also behind baby Arthur in the
background there's a Pinocchio
marionette toy Pinocchio is a weirdly
important reference point in this movie
Arthur brings him up later when he and
mera hide inside the whale and that kid
in the Sicilian town gives mera the
Pinocchio book we also learned that Tom
chose to name Arthur after king Arthur
from the Old English legend we will see
in this movie how Aquaman's story is
definitely based on Arthurian mythology
an outcast who proves his worth by
pulling a sword from a stone and
claiming his rightful place on the
throne then we see a slightly older
Arthur on a field trip to the Boston
aquarium and notice of the two bullies
mock Arthur for talking to fish Bruce
Wayne makes the same jab to Arthur in
Justice League here you can talk to fish
yes Aquaman does famously communicate
with fish I actually like how the scene
shows young art there using soundwaves
evoking Aquaman's telepathy and the
Superfriends cartoon but rather than
being a goofy gimmick in this movie this
colep a--they actually ends up being the
one thing to redeem Aquaman later in the
film more on that later then adult
Aquaman shows up he rescues the hijacks
submarine it's introduced to the villain
the Black Manta David Kane david Hyde in
the comics played by yah duel matina ii
his father tells him the story of his
grandfather who was one of the frogmen
in world war ii but the veteran wasn't
properly honored after the war the
dagger that david's father gives to him
is
symbol of this betrayal and the whole
Manta family legacy of piracy meanwhile
notice the ancestry token that Aquaman
wears this green necklace now this is a
Maori Toki jade necklace kind of like
the tattoos uma moas torso this necklace
is a nod to his Polynesian ancestry we
learned later that the reason Black
Manta and his crew hijacked this sub was
out of a conspiracy with orme
to use a human submarine in a false flag
attack against the Atlanteans to lure
them into war right before this attack
happens we meet or current ruler of
Atlantis Arthur's half-brother played by
Patrick Wilson he rides an armored Tyla
sword which is a kind of see crocodile
thing and he and his forces meet with
the kingdom of Zemel ruled by King
Marius dolph lundgren we also meet ORMs
advisor volcko played by Willem Dafoe
all during this time he's been secretly
training Arthur Currie now in total
there are seven kingdoms Atlantis devil
the fisherman kingdom the brine the
trench the deserters and the mysterious
hidden Kingdom Aurum needs four out of
the seven to agree to go to war against
the land dwellers and I like how in this
scene that ormond area is just simply
talked to each other with their voices
sounding normal under the water that was
a conscious decision by James Bond to do
away with the whole weird air bubbles
from Justice League so this false flag
submarine attack leads to ORMs worldwide
shoreline attack a tidal wave hurling
warships and trash back to the land
Arthur and his father are saved by Mara
Amber Heard returning from Justice
League she reminds Arthur that he helped
defeat Steppenwolf this is this movie's
one reference to the events of Justice
League now the news coverage of this
tidal wave features a news talk show
with dr. Stephen Shin played by Randall
Park he's a marine biologist and a
conspiracy theorist obsessed with
Atlantis in the new 52 comics he plays
an important mentor old Arthur curry and
he actually shows up in this movies
post-credits scene I made a whole other
video about that go check it out as
Arthur prepares to join Meera to help
prevent this whole war we learn in the
flashback that volcko taught him
everything he needs to know about being
an Atlantean the Trident water shield
attack that he uses to beat Oran later
but also that is Atlantean eyes can
change to be able to connect with ocean
life this actually explains why his eyes
changed to the color yellow as a kid and
why normal humans can't see the undersea
Kingdom Arthur and Meera meet with
volcko in a secret hideout a sunken ship
look closely at the ocean floor there's
a creepy little doll among the whosits
and whatsits galore this is
actually in Annabelle doll thrown in the
set by director James Wan as an easter
egg nod to his work in the conjuring and
Annabelle film series volcko tells them
about the mythical Trident of at land
now the weapon Aquaman has been using so
far that we saw in Batman V Superman and
in Justice League it's actually a Quinn
dn't it's one carried by his mother
Atlanta meanwhile the classic Trident of
Aquaman is the thing that he's after in
this movie and this whole story of how
it was forged from the power of Poseidon
this seems adapted from an object known
as the dead Kings scepter in Aquaman
Comics at land forged the dead Kings
sceptre to defend against his own
brother Oran now this leads to Arthur's
arrest he demands trial by combat to the
Ring of Fire it's a big gladiator arena
and during this fight there's a quick
shot of an awesome octopus playing the
drums this is actually character from
the comics topo it's an octopus that
Aquaman hangs out with director James
Wan said that Topa would played lots of
instruments at once they joked that he
wanted the octo drummer to hook up with
that guitar flame guy from Mad Max fury
road
Arthur loses the duel when Orem breaks
their mothers' Quinn dent and he and
Mara escape and they seek out the
deserter Kingdom and Asahara now the
pilot of this cargo plane may look
familiar to you this is Leigh Whannell
James wons longtime collaborator and
co-writer in star of the original saw
movie their discovery of these ruins
underneath the Saharan dunes leads them
to plug in this Amazon echo each
cylinder thing which requires a drop of
water to activate now this seems like a
nod to the climax of the movie The Fifth
Element with the ancient ruins and
devices that worked a real similar way
now during the film we get a flashback
to the heyday of Atlantis and it looks
amazing the design features some great
attention to detail the architecture
looks inspired by classic Roman
structures within aqueducts you can also
see a Colosseum and if you look closely
there's a structure in the shape of
Aquaman's a sigil revealing its origin
so I guess this logo didn't come from an
email attachment stolen from Lex
Luthor's archives Orem takes over the
fisherman are me with a coup a knee arms
black manta with new weaponry and
soldiers and when black mantas helmet
misfires he quips I think I'm gonna need
a bigger helmet an obvious nod to the
famous line from Steven Spielberg's jaws
our third mirror head to Sicily where
Arthur realizes at lands bottle needs to
be viewed as a telescope through the eye
of an ancient statue of King Romulus
Romulus was a real king he was the first
king of Rome according to legend he
feuded with his brother Remus and I
think this historical reference is meant
to reflect the brother relationship
between Arthur and Orman as Arthur and
Mara approached the trench they're
attacked by the terrifying trench
monsters and you can see here why James
Wan wanted to do this movie these beasts
allowed him to set up some really really
fun jump scares one did say that he was
careful to limit his horror tendencies
to certain visuals like this one rather
than the whole movie feeling like a
horror downer tone the journey through
the trench leads them to the hidden
Kingdom a surreal utopia where they
learn Atlanta is still alive I guess
that makes it the second time this year
a 90s Batman love-interest superhero
mommy wound up a lie but gray-haired in
the dream world on the other side of a
bottomless pit eyes on your own papers
Hollywood Studios Arthur journeys
through the waterfall to retrieve at
land's Trident and he must slay the
dragon so to speak in this case it's
this Lovecraftian giant keratin in this
creature is voiced by of all people
Julie Andrews amazing and while other
heroes have failed
the one thing that saves Arthur that
wins over this giant beast is his
ability to talk to fish way to turn
something kind of dumb into a point of
pride James Wan Arthur completes is
Arthurian legend he pulls a trident from
the stone he gets a sweet new green and
orange scaly armor and he arrives mid
battle to defeat warm one last little
easter egg when Oren begs Arthur to show
him no mercy Patrick Wilson screams in
anguish to kill this could be a wink to
the ending of the movie The Watchmen in
which Patrick Wilson of course played
night owl and he watched in horror as
were shark begged for execution from dr.
Manhattan in the exact same way
[Applause]
how do you guys think Aquaman ranks
among the DC EU films me I kind of liked
it I think it's up there with Man of
Steel Wonder Woman didn't feel too over
ambitious like Batman V Superman or
Justice League and it certainly wasn't a
trainwreck that Suicide Squad was
comment down below with your thoughts
and follow new rock stars on Twitter at
new rock stars follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at a loss subscribe to new
rock stars for more deep dives and
everything you love damn I said dive I
was hoping to make it through an Aquaman
video without making one corny cringy
aquatic verb I guess I'll go ask the
hollywood reporter for a job where i can
shore up a will of a headline about how
the tides are turning over head warner
brothers DC division kill me
[Music]